remember this girl hi babies never win
lady shut up you can barely see over the
table
well curly sue is all grown up now and
Allison Porter's audition on Monday
night's premiere of The Voice left all
four coaches stunned et spoke with her
Tuesday morning fresh off her viral
moment
you had all four judges turn around for
you what was your reaction to that
obviously I wanted everybody to turn
around but I didn't think that that was
gonna happen and when I stopped singing
and like came to and saw them all
standing there it was really incredible
how much was on the line there for you
really everything like the thought of
coming back into the business and taking
this risk what if it didn't work out
what if it wasn't worth it at the end of
the day I followed my gut I followed my
heart
I actually got sober almost eight years
ago and
I found love and I had children and that
was my my goal to just be a good mom
after I had my kids I thought you know
it's kind of over for me I'll make music
then I kind of just had this epiphany
like why is it over for me why would I
think that why do you think that when
you become a parent you can be a really
incredible parent and still work really
hard and follow your dreams you know